hopefully will give us some answers as
some of you might have noticed I'm not
Katrina her student and this work was
done under supervision well the the DOE
I'm supposed to have a clicker somewhere
no okay so so basically this talk in a
way he goes as far as possible from the
region of privacy in a sense nothing
that we will show here requires any
knowledge about privacy and we're not
treating privacy anymore as a tool which
is with with his own purpose and which
by the way also is a stability notion
but we're dealing only with the
stability notion luckily for us we had a
few talks during this session especially
you always now that covered the
background so I'll just mentioned in a
few words and point out the the
notations that we are going to use but
generally the form of the talk will be
mentioning the problem presenting the
definition I'll spend probably quite a
lot of time about the notation because
in a sense that's the most important
part and then see it has the nice
properties we're used to get from
stability notions and show that it
implies n is necessary for
generalization thank you
basic logic okay so this is the setting
we have distribution over the domain of
sample sets I'll mention in a moment why
we're looking at the general case where
the distribution is over the domain of
sample sets we asked queries about it
that can be you know assessing the loss
of some hypothesis or anything else
we have the true answer which is the the
assessment of the query on the sample
set we got we have the true answer in
the world which is what we want and we
have a mechanism which will soon define
that produces an answer the far the
answer usually if we didn't have any
problems with that apptivity or with
privacy we would just think about you
know providing the correct answer but we
might provide something else this
distance we call sample accuracy which
is a tool that we it's something we a
quantity we can control this
distribution accuracy what we care about
this generalization as long as the
queries are not overfitting we and we
have generalization guaranteeing of the
classical concentration bound so we're
good we know that under adaptive
composition this might not be the case
and if we don't have generalization the
question is what can we do so means it's
like one line of work uses some kind of
bound on the whole class of queries and
it says that you know you have some kind
of generalization guarantee for any
hypothesis or any query so then you're
good but if you don't have it you're in
trouble and what you need is basically
some form of stability notion so that's
why I differential privacy is here and
that's why this talk is here so it
starts with dork at all and
the improved version both in the the
factors and the proof of methods which
in a lot of ways we followed and you'll
see it along the way is by the VN sssu
paper from 2016 and summing transfers to
theorem probably all soil that
guarantees that if you're both
epsilon-delta differentially private and
epsilon-delta sample accurate then your
epsilon Delta distribution accurate and
to up to a bunch of factors now a
natural question that arises once you
look at it is well differential privacy
is in essence a worst case demand with
respect to a lot of things and most
notably
the two neighboring sample sets right we
want to protect any person from any kind
of samples that he might participate in
so for any two sample sets we need to
have a guarantee learning is a
probabilistic process so we usually need
just that with probability greater than
Delta
something will happen so it might be the
differential privacy is cake is a
definition that can be relaxed and still
provide generalization guarantees there
were a few more than a few notions of
relaxed differential privacy or relaxed
generalization notions that were
proposed along the years the the most
notable one that we will refer to as the
max information because it in some ways
we resemble it but again there were a
lot in and each one of them relaxed it
to some degree and and then a natural
question is how much further can we
relax what's the most relaxed stability
notion that we can propose that still
guarantees generalization ok so just the
setting the terminology we would use
because we've so different notation so
our domain is X the range of responses
are the mechanism receives a what you
used to think of as queries but we call
it generators because it
generates the answers but it might not
be a query and you will see like we're
starting with an analysis that is a bit
more abstract and then later we deal
with specifically with queries but for
the intuitive for the intuitive level
you can look at it as a query and and
and we want to analyze it okay so which
in order to speak about generalization
and stability we need to introduce the
distributions into it we need to
introduce the probability aspect so
basically there are two sources of
randomness one is the sampling of the
mechanism and of the sample set and as I
mentioned before we're dealing in the
general case with distributions over the
sample sets not over the sample point we
will see it makes difference when we
dealing when we when we talk about it
activity and then you have the second
distribution which is the conditional
distribution of the response given the
sample set right every sample set
induces a distribution over the response
the possible responses based on
obviously the specific generator that
was given to the mechanism comment about
notations we try to put as much of the
layers that effect the the distributions
into the notation but there is a limit
to what we can put in one slide and in
you know one paper so for instance the
mechanism is usually dropped because we
don't deal with more than one mechanism
at a time or if we do it's very clear
but basically this one should also
depend on the mechanism okay so we have
the underlying distribution over the
sample set
we will deal with it right now there's
no adaptivity but yes the mechanisms
will be able to be stateful and it it's
a very delicate issue we will touch on
it later
okay so once we have the underlying
distribution over s and the distribute
conditional distribution of our given s
well then we can define the set of
resulting distribution so first of all
we have the Joint Distribution which is
the probability to get the sample set
any response out of as the output of
that sample set we have the
unconditional or marginal distribution
of R which is just if we have a
distribution over the sample sets and we
have a mechanism that is probabilistic
by itself so it induces a marginal
distribution of the responses they have
the disjoint distribution or then
depended distribution which is just
again for a couple for a couple sample
set and a response but the probability
to get them independent of each other
and the same way we can define the
conditional distribution the other way
around the sample said given an R this
is I mean you can look at it as a formal
definition using base law and you can
look at it as it has a meaning of let's
say I don't know anything about the
sample sets but I got a response from
the mechanism what what does it tell me
about the sample set that induced this
response in a way what's the posterior
and we will use this terminology of
prior and posterior quite a lot so I
mentioned before one relaxed in a way
stability notion that was proposed also
by a volatility was max information and
intuitively max information looks that
these two quantities the two
distributions over the domain of sample
sets and the responses the joint and the
disjoint and it looks at the distance
between and they use the epsilon-delta
indistinguishability distance and they
say well if they're close and if
close enough then we must generalize
there is an issue with looking at these
distributions over the sample sets and
responses it relatively naturally
implies generalization but it's not very
clear if this can be also necessary not
just sufficient why because we're
dealing usually with queries that are
not just arbitrary queries over sample
sets the queries need to be anyway for
guarantees for generalization guarantees
we need the quiz to be either linear
queries or low sensitivity queries or
some kind of query that's not very
sensitive to a small change in the
sample set so maybe we have some very
weird behavior happening over the sample
sets but if I can't construct from it
the query that assigns a specific value
for a specific point so I might still be
generally be able to generalize even if
the distributions are relatively far
from each other so a more natural thing
to do and this is what we aim to do is
to move from distributions over the
sample sets the distribution over the
sample points formally the way we define
it is just by thinking of a sampling
mechanism a mechanism just as we defined
all of these before but this case it has
only one generator which is just please
give me randomly one of uniformly one of
your sample points and it outputs one of
the sample points it's basically the
marginal distribution over sample points
induced by the distribution over sample
sets there's no magic happening here but
once we have this we can repeat just the
last five slides but this time with
distributions over the domain of sample
points and responses okay so we'll just
go of it formally so what is the joint
distribution over X and are now not X to
the N in R so it's basically running
over all sample sets the probability to
get this X and this R from this sample
set same way we can get they're disjoint
it's independent conditioning X give
R&I sorry are given X and it's given R
and what's important is even though
which might not be clear from the way
these are defined they behave nicely
they have their base law so you know the
probability of X given R is the
probability of are given next time the
probability of X over probability of rx
it's a lemma it's not absolutely obvious
but it's it's correct ok so so far no
special magic done here we just
carefully defined using a mechanism and
a generator distributions over the
domain and over the range of responses
and any combination of them okay so when
look at it again we can realize that
basically we have now two distributions
over x one is d of x it's the prior
distribution let's say I would ask
someone before the first iteration
started some all-knowing entity some
adversary right we're going to deal with
adversary that's trying to do the worst
so let's say he knows whatever he can
and you would ask him let's say I
sampled one of the points from the
sample set but you didn't see what would
it be so you wouldn't he would tell me
the prior that's all you have to say
once he saw a response then he has a
posterior in a sense the distance
between these two distributions might be
what will will guarantee stability right
because in a sense and again always talk
also touched a lot about this subject
the the what's special about stability
more than just generalization is the
fact that not only it produces answers
that are close to the correct answers it
produces answers that the probability to
see them with and without the sample set
a simple point are very close to each
other right because if I give you a if I
encode all of the information in the
lower order bits so I can give you a
answer that is quite accurate but still
reveals too much
and any post-processing will reveal it
if I give you an answer that the
probability to get it without my sample
point was still very similar it seems
like nothing you can do will ever allow
you to extract the information so so so
we said okay so so the distance between
these two distributions is might be the
vaquita
all of it but the question is now which
distance measure is the best way to
estimate how much information was leaked
and I'm using that word information out
in the formal definition so first formal
definition we provide is the stability
loss of a response the stability loss of
a response is just the statistical
distance or also known as a total
variation distance between the
probability to get it's supposed to be X
naught B of X notation it's the
probability to have a point in in the
summing over all the the the X's in in
the domain the probability to the
difference in the probability in
absolute value or just summing over the
ones with the posterior than prior in
the same way we can define a stability
loss of a set and it's just sort of
averaging and the loss of the responses
I will write it down because we'll use
it many times the further so the loss
defined by the underlying distribution
and the generator of the R is summing of
X in
prior - posterior and when to sit and
Louis
çb of our we have a ton of set so we
always use a subscript notation to say
from where they set was taken so I'm
summing I'm gonna be I know it's
important
summing over the are in the B of our
[Music]
/ this is just the top ability of this
questions so far
the type of here is it's supposed to be
exes not Buicks summing over the X's in
the that's it's all the they're like a
few ways to write total variation
distance one is summing over all X's the
absolute value of this difference and
distance and then dividing by two
another one it's joy and enjoying it's
always better it's statistical distance
plus typo that's basically you ever
wondered how does their child look okay
and now what's local statistical
stability so a mechanism will be called
local statistically step epson losses
this is basically the average
statistical distance over those
responses right gene by averaging and
with the weighted average by their
probability yeah yeah so this is the
definition first so okay two things I
want to say first of all we know what is
this set that maximizes this quantity
it's the set of all responses that are
greater than epsilon right if you have a
response with the loss that's less than
epsilon so you plug it in here you just
reduce the size so obviously you want to
add only responses with a probability
greater than epsilon and intuitively you
can think of it as something like let's
put here is d R G of L epsilon R less
than Delta it's not true it's it's just
with the factor a factor of two in the
epsilon a factor of epsilon in the Delta
or something that's not exactly but up
to some factors this is what it says it
says the probability to get a response
for which we have a loss that is greater
than epsilon is sort of less than Delta
and maybe
the drawing will make it seem a bit more
reasonable so let's say these are the
X's and these are the ours like we have
responses and we have domains so given a
specific art I'm looking at a specific
art and I'm looking at two distributions
over this this product space
one is the Joint Distribution of X in R
and one is the district and dependent
distribution of X in R so if I'm looking
at a given R so I have now two
distributions now this is x one is this
and another one is a bit different and
it has a statistical some kind of
statistical distance between them and
statistical distance might be small
might be big if it's less than R less
than epsilon I don't care if it's bigger
than epsilon it's a problematic one so
if the set of responses which have a
statistical distance R with the two
distributions that it's induced by them
which is greater than epsilon we'll call
them Epsilon unstable responses if their
probability is too big then we have a
problem a few words of intuition about
like what's going on here so if these
two distributions are relatively far
from each other but it's it's spread
along all the responses that might not
be interesting imagine x case where for
every response you have a loss you have
a difference but the difference is like
an order of magnitude of two Delta so
overall it's more than Delta when you
sum but what happens is that no matter
what response you'll get you'll have a
slight degradation in the in the
stability that's not a problem on the
other hand if you had a ton of
degradation everybody to a loss it was
all concentrated in a very small set of
ours
I mean negligible probability it's also
not an issue if you have the set of ours
for which the probability to get them is
not negligible and the loss is is also
big enough then we have a problem that's
basically the intuition behind the de
finish
to hear that the exit of what you're
putting on the X there is a random point
from the data set right right it's it's
the distributions we defined before all
okay so we have a definition now if this
definition doesn't hold doesn't have the
nice properties of most ability notions
that it's not worth anything
post-processing I'm just gonna write it
there's nothing interesting about the
proof you can imagine if it's the
building notion over the distributions
almost all of the proofs look very
similar and it's basically it says that
any post-processing will not get these
distributions further away from each
other composition is more interesting
and we start by defining the bit for a
bit more carefully what is adaptive
composition so first we need to define
what is an adversary um we use the a it
can be an analyst or an adversary but
we're dealing with the worst case
scenario over there over oh okay so it's
worth know I said before that
differential privacy is worst case and
we don't necessarily want worst case we
don't necessarily want worst case over
the sample sets because the sample sets
come from a distribution over an analyst
we don't know what analyst we got we
might got we might be dealing with the
worst case analyst either because he's
really malicious or because some kinds
of processes get the analyst to know so
much that he's becomes dangerous and
that's one of the open questions we'll
leave to the end it really tells us to
what Adam asked like what can we have
better guarantees for analysts that are
not that dangerous anyway we're dealing
with an adversary so he knows everything
maybe so an adversary is a generator by
itself but this generate right generator
was an abstract concept now this is the
first generator which actually we say
what happens to it what does it do and
it's a function it's a function that
given a finite set of responses just
produces the next generator and we use
via view just like the classical papers
adaptive mechanism I'm not teaching
anyone anything new here
I'm just sort of using a white box
approach to this specific mechanism this
is the mechanism just before right it
gets a generator gets a sample set and
it spits out the response his responses
of you but and and what happens inside
is there's one analyst there is
something between 1 and K mechanisms
that's your question so on one hand it
can be K different mechanisms if I want
to deal with that kind of case in the
other case it can be just one mechanism
and then it will be stateful anything is
possible in this scenario there is a
adaptive interaction between the
adversary and the mechanisms and in
order to be coherent we didn't want the
adversary to be in control of the
probabilistic aspect because we said the
mechanism is the one that has that
probability so so the mecha the
adversary the adaptive mechanism just
chooses the coin tosses and handed hands
them to the adversary it doesn't change
anything because the internal sub
mechanisms don't know it in the view
which is this is a slight change from
sorry the notation and a B NSSE the
views only include the responses and the
coin tosses at the barrier the first
coin toss if it was needed and then
every generator is a deterministic
function of the previous view which is
important just for the analysis ok so
now we can define what scalar says so
being calluses means a sequence of K
mechanisms which shares state not
whatever you want is calluses if-then
adaptive mechanism analysis and the
theorem states that if any of the
mechanisms is epsilon I if Delta I
differentially perm LS s then they all
together are the sum of its own sum of
Delta's calluses
the proof itself is relatively tedious
but there's one step there that I think
is crucial and it really resembles what
Alan mentioned before and that's the
idea of looking at the posterior
distribution so in a sense that's why
there are only two real insights here
first it's understanding that the this
any iteration can be thought of as the
first iteration in a world where the
prior distribution is the posterior of
the previous view and the mechanism is
maybe a slightly different mechanism
behaving with all the previous knowledge
so here there was another part of the
slide we want we omit it because it just
looked too crowded but this is not
necessarily correct here we're assuming
that the mechanism depends only on the
sample set and the generator and we say
oh the generator is a deterministic
function of the previous view if it had
internal probe state so you would just
need to add here given whatever we know
about the the process that happened so
far but again it's just a different kind
of mechanism with a different internal
distribution it's a different kind of
distribution over the sample sets this
is the Z we used here and other than
that that's it so every and and so okay
so what I said two insights one is every
iteration is the first iteration and
then the distances just have triangle
inequality it's a statistical distance
over a given set so basically that's all
that's happening here this is probably
the best time to explain why did we
speak about distributions over sample
sets and not over sample points because
even if we started from distributions
that is that is a product distribution
the second iteration already the
posterior might not be a product
distribution therefore we had to be
dealing with generally distribution over
sample sets and another thing I don't
know if I pointed it out clearly enough
here
this theorem holds only four mechanisms
which were epsilon-delta LSS for any
distribution and it's important because
we didn't we emit it emitted it for most
definitions here in the slide band the
paper we were very very careful most
definitions are dependent on like I'm
accurate or or not accurate I'm stable
or anything like that for a given
generator for a given adversary for
given etc this one has to be for all
distributions why because we don't know
what distributions will be induced by
the posterior once we start getting
answers okay so what's left
generalization so linear queries they
don't need to teach you about that only
we use the notation of Delta bounded
linear queries which are from minus
Delta to Delta and we use a Q Delta and
again revisiting the definitions of
sample accuracy and distribution
accuracy just using now our notations so
again this is the sample accuracy this
is distribution accuracy similar
definition for a sequence of queries
we're taking the maximum over all of the
answers it can be either defined
relative to just a sequence of queries
or relative to an adversary which
creates this sequence of queries okay so
how does the how do we prove that LS s
imply generalization by almost copying
what they didn't be NS s SEO using the
same monitoring mechanism I painted this
in red because well almost all of the
letters now all the letters are here so
you might be upset for first I emitted
the part we're because we need the sign
to be positive so we might flip the the
minus and also here there's a slight
flaw you know q is not part of V in our
notation it's just a deterministic
function of it but up to these two
caveats it's it's the same mechanism
just a reminder to ever they read the
paper by coincidence
so this mechanism
gets an adversary gets a vector of
sample sets tt sample sets it runs the
adaptive mechanism between the mechanism
or mechanisms and the adversary T
independent times and then chooses from
all the durations from all the queries
and responses within the iteration the
worst one worse than the sense of the
highest distribution in accuracy and how
does it know it because the mechanism
this out mechanism knows the real
distribution obviously it's a contrived
example it's not a normal situation but
it's a thought experiment the idea is
that since we proved post-processing and
an adapted composition so each of these
steps is is LSS and since alice's holds
under post-processing it should hold
even under post-processing of doing
something with the underlying
distribution and therefore we can prove
that even the whole process is LSS where
the degradation is only in the Delta
parameter or not in the epsilon because
it was independent
so we state this theorem with parameters
that are looking a bit funky here but
other than that it's like relatively
classical if your epsilon Delta ok Allah
says and your epsilon Delta ok simple
accurate your epsilon Delta K
distribution accurate the proof just
like a general reminder to
okay so well just remind what happens
here so we're looking at the expectation
of the of the difference between these
two quantities okay so there's the
expected sample error expected
distribution error and expected
generalization error and what we say is
that since we are sample accurate and
these are T independent distributor
iterations we end teeth chosen to be
order of 1 over Delta so it's T times
Delta X or it's order 1 the same thing
we proved with with LSS since the
probability to get a unsteady nipson on
stable response is less than Delta so
repeating at T times is less than T
times Delta and if you're not
distribution accurate since we're
choosing the worst one so the
probability that none of them will be
too bad is 1 minus 1 minus Delta to the
power of T which is about 1 over epsilon
over ears again the order of 1 so if you
play correctly with the factors you
reach a contradiction where you can
prove this by triangle inequality is too
small and here it says it's stupid
that's basically the idea of the proof
there and we repeat it nothing
interesting here now do the suppose the
interesting part we claim that it's also
necessary and not just sufficient how do
we do that by constructing a query that
actually uses the difference in the
distribution so given a view or a
response will be the same we're dealing
now with you so that's why we use this
notation given a view we assign a delta
or minus delta to any point in the
domain depending on if the prior is
higher than the posterior or the
posterior higher than the prior meaning
that the expectation of over the domain
given space view or the just the prior
expectation will be as far away from
each other as we can and once we do that
we
exactly the same idea with the
monitoring mechanism the only changes
what do we do after each iteration so
again we run T independent times the
monitoring mechanism the adaptive
mechanism we get a V we construct an
overfitting query the loss assessment
query using that V and we feed it to the
mechanism its that K plus 1 iteration
and we get a response and again we
choose the one which was supposed to
have the worst overfitting this and
output that and its response and the
theorem says that very similarly if you
want to be epsilon Delta KL is said if
if you are not epsilon Delta KL SS you
can't be both epsilon Delta distribution
and sample accurate with k plus 1
because again we constructed one extra
iteration and again we have the same
issue was only mentioned like maybe
there is some like weird mechanism that
can maintain distribution accuracy and
after losing sample accuracy and then it
can do better but as long as you have to
be both sample and distribution accurate
we prove that you must be KL SS and the
proof is exactly the same same
expectation same thing just now these
two are bounded from above by T times
Delta which is all run and this one is
greater than its order of 1 also because
we chose the worst here the worst is in
the sense of the generalization ability
ok so just to recap what happened the
the problem of generalization guarantee
under adaptivity is no problem there is
a whole line of guarantees based on
stability notions that started by
differential privacy we proposed a new
definition of stability which a has the
properties that are similar to the rest
of stability notions most importantly
post-processing an adaptive composition
and its bow
sufficient and necessary for
generalization under the assumption of
sample accuracy there are a few more
things we were working on which we
didn't get to one is advanced adaptive
composition the same way we have with
differential privacy in a sense you can
almost see what it happened here I know
I don't have this lie but basically as I
told you this we used triangle
inequality now these are independent in
some ways so as long as you have a bound
and the expectation you can do again
some some trick proposing it as a
martingale and using the Zuma inequality
but we don't think there is a guarantee
and the expectation there is direct
result of just this definition we think
we have a separating example for max
information right until now I showed
that this definition is both sufficient
and necessary but no one said it's not
equivalent to other definitions that are
known particular max information maybe
so we think we have an example where max
information were for a mechanism that is
not max information and yet it is it
will remain generalizing and what really
bothers us and we're starting to work on
is providing generalization guarantees
directly without sample accuracy it's
we're not sure about the necessary but
the sufficient and we're not sure about
the sufficient but necessary we think we
have an example proof the main open
first of all it opens probably a variety
of opportunities and questions the main
ones are first time can we propose any
new algorithm or existing algorithm with
different parameters that can do better
for generalization purposes we know
using the lower bounds that only
mentioned that in the most general case
we can't beat the the K squared
parameter but maybe other dependencies
can be improved more importantly what
happens if it
one of the aspects of the way we
presented everything is that every
theorem and every definition might be
distribution dependent might be that
adversary dependent etc so the question
is if we limit yourself to a family of
distributions if we limit ourselves the
family of queries or what makes more
sense is a limited family of adversaries
for instance Adam chose open question
maybe if the adversary and doesn't have
any information of the mechanism doesn't
have maybe we can have better guarantees
I mean also there's the issue of
extension to other types of queries um
differential privacy was proven also for
lowest low sensitivity queries we didn't
do it yet I'm here for two more weeks
and I'll be more than happy to sit and
talk with who and any of you will think
that it's worth my time so thank you
very much
[Applause]
you go back just a separation question
I'm not sure what sort of separation you
have in mind but I guess one thing that
separates all these information
guarantees from generalization
guarantees is if you put the first 20
data points for something in the clear
is like possibly unbounded amount of
information about the data set but it
doesn't really mess with generalization
too much is is that the sort of
separation you have in mind or is it are
you looking for something more so so
what you're mentioning is so so the
question is what's the distribution you
have over the sample set so I'll just
mention like and report my our example
is for for distributions even over
product distributions and any kind of
product distribution basically the idea
is let's say we have it's a finite very
large set and the the response is
basically taking the sample set breaking
it to pieces of size let's say n epsilon
squared so even knowing it this not
enough and you have a bunch of them and
then also randomly breaking the rest of
the of the domain to pieces the same
size and then releasing this this how do
you a grouping of the domain in no
particular order so no one knows which
one of them are in the set what you
basically the only information you
reveal is that for each one of these
subsets the sample set either includes
all of it or none of it that's the
general mechanism now any distribution
the the the the change in the in the
distribution over the sample sets and
the distribution over the sample sets is
dramatically right
because most of the weight of the
distribution was on on sample sets that
included fractions of these so you
emitted almost all of the distribution
but on the other hand if n is big enough
greater n is larger than epsilon squared
like it's absolutely one over epsilon to
the fourth or whatever you can look at
it even as just like each one of them is
one quantity and still have the
classical concentration bounds so in a
sense what you have is like for almost
any product distribution in any yeah any
any product distribution in any domain
that is large enough you can break this
max information and still remain with
generalization guarantees we already
know that like compression schemes that
might release you know like learning a
real-valued interval yeah right so it's
really a single data point generalize is
unbounded facts information are you
looking for like a different kind of
separation it's okay so first of all
it's not just generalized I want
generalization guarantees here I have
generalization guarantees because even
after so it doesn't contradict the the
post-election example that's because
exactly what Katrina is that there's at
the end of the talk there is a very
delicate thing about what happens when
you deal with order so either you deal
with order sets if the ordered sets are
defined in advance so then you need to
define what exactly is accuracy because
is is the order can it play a role in
accuracy or not and if the order is
defined in a synthetic way for instance
we take part of the bits and say ooh
that defines order then you're not low
sensitive so if you're using so now the
way we we presented all of it you can
either choose to have the sample sets
ordered or not ordered it doesn't matter
but
then it's careful to define what is what
is accuracy in this case because
just a very good comment I mean we do
know quite there are natural mechanisms
which are not simple accurate but
generalize for example magnets it the
first use say one part of the subsidy
tell they see that they stop overfitting
on that and then use the other we want
answers please once they see that there
is already too much overfitting on the
first parts of a these mechanism will
not be accurate from the entire samples
because there may be only accurate on
you on a fraction of it then along just
proving growing things about these
mechanism in this interesting stuff
beyond the vectors which are somewhat
and and and we we tried to play with a
few things that the problem is a lot of
the times you can model these mechanisms
as a bunch of sub mechanisms interacting
between them and then okay so you have
the guarantee breaking broken for each
one of them and if not so so but but but
yes it's a big question that the main
thing is that it feels very natural that
if the mechanism if you have a
overfitting query all you need to do is
to make sure the mechanism can't know if
now you're proposing an overfitting
query or not and then he doesn't know if
to believe the data or not right if you
manage to figure that what that one out
that's it you don't need to deal with
sample accuracy the question is its well
we didn't find it it's a way to prove
that the mechanism can't tell if it's
one of the overfitting queries or not
that's me
[Applause]